hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in chapter 12 of his work on controlling
anger Plutarch is going to focus in on
one of the main causes for people
becoming angry and he's drawing on other
thinkers who have come before him in
that very chapter he mentions Jerome who
was an Aristotelian whose work on anger
unfortunately is lost some of the things
that Plutarch is saying Echo things that
Aristotle earlier had said in rhetoric
book two and he is providing us with a
way of understanding how we can avoid
becoming angrier as intensely angry if
we can see one of the main causes for
anger so cut off the cause cut off the
effect so he's looking or literally
theorizing about the origin the Genesis
the coming to be
of anger itself and he says something
very interesting here that is worth
noting he tells us that there are
multiple causes right A Cause is idea in
Greek and he says that there's different
causes for different people to become
angry so it's not as if there's one
single button that we can push all the
time but then he goes on and he says in
the uh for the most part in most cases
in the majority of cases however we want
to translate this
Epi acos hapasi right so what is it that
actually brings about anger it could be
all sorts of things but the Common
Thread seems to be a belief a doxa or
appearance if you like a belief of what
that somebody is showing contempt
catafrones thy that is that one is being
looked down upon Kata is downward frones
is you know to think about or to look at
or to regard so being regarded as lesser
being looked down upon or neglect I'm a
lace thigh so
um Malaya is care concern paying
attention to prioritizing so a lack of
being prioritized or cared for by others
so you know you could translate this as
contempt and neglect as it is in many of
the translations and it's by other
people these are passive verbs which
imply that somebody is doing something
to you
so he says that this you know is
something that that very often happens
and I'm actually going to skip a little
bit to to later on at the very end of
this section he says if we consider
ourselves despised we will not only
harshly treat people who are close to us
in the same you know household you could
say wife or spouse and servants and
friends but also we're going to look at
this list we're going to follow with
innkeepers and sailors and drunken mule
drivers we even rage against dogs that
bark at us and asses that jostle us like
the man who wished to beat the ass
driver but when the driver cried out I'm
an Athenian indicated the ass and said
you had any radar not an Athenian and
then began beating the ass the animal
the Beast of Burden right so if we do
allow ourselves to think that we are
being treated with contempt or
carelessness or something like that
people aren't you know giving us our
proper respect we're going to get ticked
off and blow up and act like jackasses
in relation to them so what can we do
he tells us that one of the things we
really need to do is when we're starting
to become angry he says we should assist
those who Endeavor to avoid anger we
should come to their aid by removing as
far as possible the act the the action
the proxy right the proxene that Rouses
Anger from any suspicion suspicion of of
what uh sliding olegorea in this case
oligoria by the way was sort of the
overarching you could say category that
contempt fit into for Aristotle Plutarch
seems to be using it more or less along
the same lines as showing contempt or
neglect right so any uh amount or any
suspicion of sliding on the other
person's part not treating us the way we
need to be treated or irrigance
right uh you could say overconfidence
being being full of oneself is another
way of expressing it so how do we remove
this suspicion when we're talking to
another person no no that's not the case
or Talking to Ourselves well we are
talking about motives here so we need to
attribute different motives which may or
may not be the the case I mean it could
be that somebody actually is being a
jerk to us deliberately but it might be
a whole bunch of other things and so he
gives us a list of different things that
we could assume that it is
we impute it to ignorance agnote us not
knowing something like you know so
somebody says something bad about
philosophers to me well they don't know
that I'm a philosopher right uh or they
don't know that uh I'm touchy about that
sort of thing or what else ignorance
necessity
um needing to to you know say something
right
um or ananke in this case right or
um pothos emotion it could be that
they're angry themselves so they say
something mean to me because they're mad
the boss left them in the the the ditch
you know and didn't they've got all
these packages that they're trying to uh
take care of and the rain is coming down
and they're all pissed off and they yell
at me right I could say well
they're suffering from a passion or
maybe they're sad they're depressed or
maybe they're you know drunk and and
enjoying themselves too much so they say
jackass things to me and I I can let
that slide in that case right
um what else could it be bad luck or
mischance as it's being translated here
um
now tujhe is chance or luck in Greek
right and so Deuce is bad Dusty means
like well things didn't go the way that
you had actually planned them to go so
you know you're walking along and you
bump somebody you didn't mean to bump
them you just happened to be in the
wrong place at the wrong time that would
be a good example of a Dusty a bad luck
so if we attribute these things to the
people instead of sliding or contempt or
arrogance or you know neglect of us then
we're not going to get mad or we're not
going to get as mad with them
and he goes on and he says that um
you know when people are being humble
with us and saying oh I'm sorry then
they don't show contempt to us they
actually show us that we matter and so
he says when he's he who has done an
injury shows himself humble he removes
all notion of contempt but we shouldn't
have to wait for others to Humble
themselves or apologize according to
Plutarch when we're angry we can
actually like take some control over our
own life and emotions and decide not to
consider Nomi Zain in Greek not to deem
ourselves to be despised by these other
people instead now here's where it gets
kind of funny he actually uses the same
term he says we should despise or
contempt we should look down on these
other people who we think are looking
down on us as acting from something bad
on their own part we could say sort of
similar to the advice that likes of
stuff Ox provide we can say oh you poor
bastard you can't do anything other than
you're doing why well there's a whole
list of six different things here
um two of which have to do with age
right one one is old age uh gerros and
the other one is childishness so we can
say that somebody is being you know like
a senile old person forgetting things
like forgetting who we are or we could
say ah you know they're acting like like
a child no no big deal right we don't
have to get upset with them and what are
the other things uh well weakness
ostenian you know maybe they don't take
stress very well maybe they don't take
challenges or setbacks or you know
getting wet and then they act like jerks
to us they're not actually trying to
show us contempt they're just weak or
maybe you know like when it comes to
seating at an event Maybe be somebody's
not very good with seating charts or
numbers or or things like that we say
well you know it's a mistake that you
made but it's it's uh not that big of a
deal rashness being too you know ready
to to do things
um propetion literally you know jumping
into things too too quickly
umian is kind of similar
um translated as as carelessness also
could be translated as being like too
easy with our commitments or things like
that and then finally uh it's translated
here as illiberality but it really means
something like being stingy being
ungenerous being the kind of person who
won't help others out a great example of
this in a very trivial uh way not giving
so much money but rather of time and
attention you know you're coming behind
somebody do they actually hold the door
open for you as you're going or are they
like screw that guy you know that would
be an example of what we're talking
about here as a kind of stinginess but
it could also be in money it could be in
all sorts of things so if we look down
on these other people we're not going to
be as bothered because we're going to be
like they don't really matter that much
because look at what a screw-up they are
you know is this a great piece of advice
uh you have to decide that for yourself
he also tells us in that same passage
when it comes to the people that we're
close with we really need to avoid
attributing this notion of contempt or
neglect to friends to servants to our
spouses or significant others and to our
family members why does it sometimes
appear as if they are you know presuming
or expecting something from us because
they actually value US so the the
tendency to feel or think that we're not
being valued because of the way that
behave they behave is sometimes stemming
directly from the fact that they
actually do value US right so he he goes
on and he says that our servants presume
on our upright character our Epi achia
being a decent person
our friends presume on our affection or
good will or you annoy towards them and
so you know they're they're actually not
thinking that we're impotent or
ineffectual they're actually thinking
that we can do things and they're hoping
and expecting for something good from us
uh you know that we are stone that is
good to them or affectionate towards
them they're not actually looking down
on us they're actually treating us as if
we're people who will give these nice
things to them so if we remind ourselves
of that then when the servant we don't
really have servants all that much
unless we're rich but you know serving
people are too familiar with us and seem
to presume we can be like ah you know
they they do that because they actually
think that I'm a decent person when our
friends uh demand or expect or you know
things things along those lines from us
we can say well I mean they expect us to
be behaving like good friends and
benefiting them and showing them Good
Will and affection so they're not really
taking advantage of us now that
you know maybe in some cases they could
be but Plutarch says it could be very
helpful for us to deliberately think
about how we're interpreting things and
then choose an interpretation of other
people's motives that leaves out this
belief of contempt or neglect by others
and if we do so then we will be less
angry and we can also use this as an aid
to help other people be less angry and
suggesting alternate motives for why
people are doing things